hi my name is Aishwarya and I work as a
researcher at Microsoft Research India
i'm here to introduce wiki Pasha to you
this is a new tool that allows
Wikipedians to create multilingual
content as you know every wikipedia
article is created from scratch in every
language what is nice about the stool is
that it allows you to leverage the
existing large repository of english
wikipedia articles as you create content
in your own language what this means is
that you do not have to be a subject
matter expert to contribute also you do
not have to be familiar with the wiki
format because the tool presents a
simplified user interface for editing so
let's see how this works I'd like to
contribute to a Wikipedia article on a
subject that I'm interested in the
southern Indian classical dance bharata
natyam so I look for the Bharata Natyam
page in my local language Hindi and this
is the page open here you can see that
this is a stub there's not very much
content on the left pane you can see a
list of languages which also have
bharata natyam wikipedia articles so i
look for the english article and here
you see a very well filled in Wikipedia
article there's a lot of content which I
can possibly use in creating the Hindi
Wikipedia page for bharatnatyam so let's
say I am interested in adding this
particular piece of information from the
English page the fact that Bharata
Natyam as a dance is inspired by the
sculptures of an ancient temple in
southern India called Chidambaram
you will see that after invoking wiki
Pasha we are still on Wikipedia and will
continue to remain there for the entire
session the content creation process
involves three steps the first of which
is collection of relevant information to
add to the page on the top left you will
see the target article that we are
working on in this case bharathanatyam
in hindi wikipedia in the left pane is
the original English Wikipedia article
on Bharata Natyam which is read only in
the right pane is a translation of the
english wikipedia article which we can
now edit notice that there is
synchronized scrolling and parallel
highlighting of sentences this is the
sentence I want to contribute to the
Hindi Wikipedia article this is
machine-translated and so I may want to
make a few edits before i submit it
there are two ways to make edits you
could type directly in the right pane
when you hover the mouse over any
sentence you will see a pop-up with the
original English sentence clicking on
the more translations link here will
bring up other translations of the
sentence that have been contributed by
members of the community the first
suggestion is always the Machine
translated version in this case I'd like
to select option three once I click on
it it replaces the existing sentence in
the article on the other hand I could
improve one of the listed suggestions by
directly editing the sentence in the
pop-up window once I submit this
translation it immediately becomes
available to all other users in the
community if I wanted to add content
from related Wikipedia pages I could
just follow the link to the page or I
could search for a particular turn and I
will see a list of options of Wikipedia
pages that are both in English as well
as the target language I can also access
any of the Wikipedia pages I have
visited by going to the visited topics
drop down
once I have finished editing I can now
move on to step two which is composing
the article in the target language in
the left pane is the content that I
worked on in the previous step and in
the right pane is the target article 2
which I want to contribute I select the
content I want to contribute I copy it
and I paste it in the target article I
can also add new content to the article
by directly typing into the right-hand
pane now that i have finished composing
the article i can move on to the next
step which is submitting it to wikipedia
the article i composed is now presented
in wiki format in wikipedia edit page i
can now preview my submission and even
at this stage i can make further edits
like resolving red links or formatting
changes etc the preview looks fine I can
now submit the article i have the
flexibility to work on as little as one
word or as much as an entire article in
one wiki pasha session and when i'm done
the content i've worked on is
immediately submitted to wikipedia in
just a few minutes I've been able to
contribute to the Bharat Natyam
wikipedia article in my own language try
it for an article that you care about
you